hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Korra episode for video
probably one of my favorite core
episodes of all time it also had like
one of the best animation sequences in
the series so far it was crazy
so I'll start with my top 5 moments then
do my review and a new round of the
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment break also recently did a Q&A on
the Avatar wiki so this is some really
important stuff so I'll explain what
that is after I get through my review
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet here we go number 5
Airbender Mission Impossible there was
this really nice thing going on between
the chorus storyline and the Airbender
storyline where the episode was called
the calling but metaphorically neither
one of those two groups could hear the
message until they dropped their baggage
there's both emotional and physical
components that - obviously Korra had
the metal bits the airbenders had the
bag of food somatically I didn't think
the storyline synced up quite as much
but you get the idea both groups had
things that they had to deal with before
they could move on the small fines
refusing to let them leave was also a
nice callback to team and getting caught
really it's the tree that teaches
everyone the lesson you know the tree is
the swamp so technically the tree is
doing everything Melo's lying about
trying to toughen up Jinora and Ikki was
a good way to explain the whole arc of
the episode I tried to toughen up these
ladies but it was a team effort the
funny thing is is that kind of makes it
sound like meelo as a representation of
the Banyan Grove tree it just makes me
low sound as big as he thinks he is in
his own head like meelo does have kind
of a big head on his Maul like the way
he's drawn he has a big head but
metaphorically speaking he has the
biggest head on the show or the biggest
ego one of these days I really want like
a milot comic just by himself it was
kind of nice to see him fall in love
just a little bit that was a very
anything to do I always thought of meelo
it's like an anchor
he's like a reincarnation of Aang even
though technically core is the
reincarnation of Aang
it was just like a very classic and
Katara moment number for Ikki with the
guards we were kind of disconnected from
what was going on in the rest of the
world this also informs us that kuvira's
marching almost the entire army on
xiaofu which i guess is gonna go down
next week I love how Ikki ended up
turning into this Miyazaki type
precocious little girl winning over the
guards instantly I know it kind of
seemed like she wasn't aware that they
wanted to capture Korra but it's a bit
at the end whenever she figured out that
she was in the swamp kind of made me
feel like she knew what was going on the
whole time like she was just playing a
little game with the guards one of my
favorite things about animation in
general not just anime is that the
children are usually smarter than the
adults South Park is probably the best
example that but it feels like the
younger you are the more profound wisdom
you get to impart to people like even
Korra learns a lot from Jinora who is
much much younger
although Jinora and Tenzin are probably
an even better comparison and who else
is really digging like all the maps on
Korra
some of them are kind of funny but most
of them look pretty cool I hope they
released like an avatar map book at some
point it's like a Song of Ice and Fire
has this really mind-blowing book of
maps I really want one for Last
Airbender and Korra that just shows all
the different maps from the different
eras of each of the avatars
even just like a detailed encyclopedia
about all the avatars since avatar Wan I
mean there have been thousands of
avatars so I don't expect them to write
something about each and every one of
them but even just their names would be
amazing number three storytime with Toph
this was amazing it was like hardcore
fanservice I threw some rocks at the
Avatar he whined what's there to tell I
think a giant turtle showed up I just
love that as Toph has gotten older her
personality has regressed back to what
it was like during last airbender like
in the Lin flashbacks during book three
the middle-aged Toph looked very
burdened with the problems of holding
public office it totally makes sense
that after she dropped that ball and
chain she just start loosening up again
I would say Last Airbender Toph seemed
like the most chill of all the
characters like she was the most in tune
with nature I don't know that I'd call
her a hippie but she was kind of like a
hippie like avatars version of what
hippies are like not to be confused with
hipsters like Skrillex but really you
have like a really balanced person like
Toph who has two children that rebel by
going in completely opposite directions
in the extreme like Lin gets super
hardcore and su Yin turns into like this
super duper New Wave hippie it really
makes you feel like Toph is the wisest
person in the avatar universe right now
like she's the only one that's
completely balanced number two Korra at
the Banyan Grove tree lots of crying
going on in the last five minutes of
this episode the banyan tree animation
was very similar almost exactly the way
they animated The Last Airbender scene
with a
they're just the way they see through
the root system to find people there's
always been something about the swamp
that makes it seem like a spiritual
shield like there's so much spiritual
energy crackling around individual
people are just impossible to pinpoint
and how about tops lesson two Cora
there's actually this saying that you
know bad luck and good luck come in
threes so that's all I could think about
whenever she was having visions of her
three previous enemies that was just a
badass animation sequence in general
just the way they superimpose those
moments I'm wondering if that's the last
time we're gonna see them ostensibly if
Korra got rid of the baggage they're not
gonna be rattling around in her head
anymore we really only tend to see
things in episodes the core is actively
thinking about unless they're like
physically right in front of her face I
know everyone's really wondering if
we're gonna see the former avatar lives
again the comics are kind of a backdoor
to that but break said that for the most
part they didn't want core to have that
crutch to lean on in book 4 and by
number one moment
Korra restores her avatar state thus her
vacation from being the avatar comes to
an end does anyone else feel like Korra
is her own worst enemy like she almost
has unlimited power but because mentally
she's been unable to process what's been
going on she pretty much neutralizes
herself like that's what all the
villains have been trying to do to her
basically get rid of the avatar and she
kind of did it for him she is fixed
though now so we can resume the action
of the season the metalbending scene
probably the most beautiful animation
I've seen on Korra ever it's only
episode four so I'm expecting something
even better later this season let me
know that what was your favorite moment
from the episode and here's the details
on that really big stuff they were
talking about during the Q&A session so
first off they did say that baby daddies
would be revealed
Michael DiMartino specifically said
there would be more tough in book four
after this episode it was in response to
someone asking you know would we find
out who the baby daddies are and he just
said stay tuned more tough coming just
implying that they would be revealing
who those people were the other really
big thing is that there's gonna be lots
more last airbender comics and Korra
stuff from Dark Horse no more TV shows
like they've said of course but lots
more comics Dark Horse has been their
publisher and they said that they're
really excited to do more comics don't
expect any new avatars anytime soon but
it is possible after they've felt like
they've done all the Korra
stories that they wanted to they could
introduce a new avatar in the comics I
know everyone always asked where to buy
the comics I know they carry Matt Barnes
& Noble they probably carry Matt like a
lot of large change but if your local
comic book store doesn't have him if you
make a big enough stick I'm sure they'll
start carrying him overall I gave the
episode a solid b-plus the Korra
storyline was totally amazing I don't
feel like the Airbender half of the
episode was quite as strong even though
it was really enjoyable like I think it
would have been stronger if they woulda
led with the Jinora story like she was
having some trouble with her spiritual
radar I feel like if they had just led
with that story it would have synched up
more with Cora's own mental problems he
had a really nice storyline about being
left out of the action like her siblings
never include her that would have just
rank a little bit stronger if it had
been something closer to what Korra had
been going through like Korra is only
ever included in the action people only
ever want to include her so it's like
the direct opposite of what happens to
Ikki metaphorically like all the beats
in the episode worked for me I just feel
like both those storylines could have
synched up just a little bit better but
QA coming tomorrow so leave all your
questions and if you haven't seen my
other videos this week Constantine is
premiering on NBC tonight so be sure to
check it out it's gonna be a lot of fun
it's one of the new DC Comics TV shows
it's based on the Hellblazer comics I
will be posting a review after that airs
so that'll be much much later tonight so
right now you can click here for the Q&A
video and you can click here for last
week's Korra episode if you haven't seen
it I've been doing some Korra gameplay
on my game channel so there's a link to
that in the description too thanks so
much for watching so that's all high
five and I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]